I'll be talking about a much more
focused project much more limited in
scope but hopefully somewhat interesting
our research is motivated by obviously
the recent growth and diffusion of
online peer-to-peer marketplaces Airbnb
for renting people's apartments and uber
for right sharing are just the two most
popular examples and these marketplaces
have received a lot of media attention
partly because of the regulatory issues
that arise with them but also because of
the very interesting problems that can
you see everything I'm not sure you can
see all of the slides
and they're very interesting because of
all the exciting economic problems that
arise in creating well-functioning and
efficient marketplaces that match many
fragmented buyers and sellers and from
our perspective what is a key feature of
these marketplaces is that they have a
varying level of buyers and sellers
varying across cities and over time and
these buyers and sellers use basically
similar rules of interaction and so we
can actually observe multiple markets
and estimate something useful about the
utilities of the buyers and sellers
participating in these platforms so let
me be specific about this if you think
about uber about using uebert uber to
get to the airport you want to find a
ride right here and right now you're not
interested in finding a ride that's one
hour late or somewhere else at the same
time if you want to look for a room on
air B&B for this workshop you want it
probably close to campus and for the
right dates and when these the markets
are temporally and geographically
defined there can be large imbalances
between buyers and sellers this is just
an example taken from uber in a
Philadelphia you can see that there's a
lot of Peaks both within a day and
across the week and I'm sure chris is
going to talk about this later this
afternoon and a basic problem for these
marketplaces is understanding how the
market equilibrates when there is
there's these large demand and supply
imbalances we're going to study this
question on TaskRabbit which is a
two-sided platform for local services
you can think of a place where you can
find someone to build your ikea
furniture for you we're going to look at
the platform between jun 2010 and may
2014 which is the period in which buyers
with post tasks like this and sir
and sellers could search through these
tasks and then submit offers very much
like a procurement auction for most of
the tasks this is a very local platform
buyers and sellers use the platform just
within their city more than ninety six
percent of sellers and buyers submit
offers or post tasks in only one city in
a given month and at the same time
matches have to occur quickly not as
quickly as an uber but about in a matter
of a couple of days and this is the
typical demand that I want you to think
about this platform is used for moving
help for home repairs and spring
cleaning and of course because it's
flexible enough to adapt to very
heterogeneous demand there's also some
typical tasks that are being posted
online like pet sitting for your
goldfish or helper from MacGyver but
really what this paper is about is not
so much about the heterogeneity of the
platform but about the aggregate market
averages for the standard task so if we
pose if we plot the number of posted
tasks in a given city over time for each
month you can see that the platform has
been growing over time but you can also
see that the number of approved sellers
has been fluctuating a lot so that there
are months in which demand is high
relative to the number of approved
sellers and there are months in which
demand is fairly low relative to the
number of approved sellers so when there
are these these fluctuations the most
obvious candidate to clear this market
is price which should be high in
principle when demand is high and low
otherwise but surprisingly enough the
average price stays pretty constant at
about sixty dollars and you can think of
these price as the price paid for a
couple of hours of
another option is that because this
market is a frictional market it is also
possible that buyers when they are in
abundance relative to sellers basically
have just a harder time finding matches
and so the task match rate should be
lower when demand is high and high
otherwise so if we plot this task met
rate this is somewhat somehow happens
but not quite enough to clear the the
market so you have a lower tax rate in
these periods of high demand and a
higher tax rate otherwise but not quite
enough and so the last possibility is
seller effort when demand doubles
relative to the number of sellers each
seller is going to perform almost twice
as many services and the way in which
task rabbit the task rabbit markets
equilibrate is through a very flexible
labor supply but why do we care whether
it's by rationing the seller's supply or
other forms of market clearing well we
care about it because this has very
important welfare implications for the
amount of well for creating and for its
distribution across by your sellers and
the platform itself and so we're going
to build a very simple model of demand
and supply for services with search and
matching frictions to estimate these
gains from trade generated by
peer-to-peer markets for domestic tasks
and this model is also going to allow us
to understand how the efficiency of the
map these matching process varies as the
market grows our their economies of
scale and across different cities why
San Francisco more efficient and
matching buyers and sellers than for
example Miami okay so without going into
the details of the model much i'm just
going to describe the basic facts there
is a measure of B of identical buyers
and the measure FS of identical sellers
each buyer is going to choose a number
of tasks to post that's it
their intensity decision beta and each
seller is going to choose a number of
offers to submit Sigma we're now going
to model the decision to participate in
the platform importantly and the number
of trades m and price are going to
determine in the aggregate as a function
of the total offers and the total tasks
posted on on the platform these are
going to be known to each buyer and
seller but each buyer and seller is not
going to be able to affect these
aggregate functions because they are
small relative to the market they're
going to take into account though the
match rate and the price in their
optimal decision of effort and how many
tasks to submit so if we're going to
look at the problem from the point of
view of the sellers we're going to have
a marginal benefit curve that depends on
the probability of being matched on the
price at which the seller is going to
perform the task minus the opportunity
cost of performing that task and then
we're going to have a tau which is a
commission fingered the platform charges
which is fixed at twenty percent this is
this marginal benefit curve is flat
because each seller is not going to be
able to affect the metroid nor the price
at the same time we assume an increasing
marginal cost of searching and
submitting offers you can think of it
you can think that that happens because
conditional on being present on the
platform it might be easy to find the
first attractive task to which to submit
offers but it might become increasingly
difficult to find more profitable tasks
for you to perform so the equilibrium is
going to be at the intersection of these
of these two curves but equilibrium has
to be consistent also with the market
average levels of tasks and offers
submitted and so we can actually draw
the market level marginal benefit curve
where every other seller that we were
not considering here in this individual
problem is actually exerting the same
level of effort as our seller of
interest and so as every seller submits
more offers every offer is going to be
less likely to be accepted qsr is going
to decrease and it's going to pay a
lower price because there's higher
competition for for each task and so the
magic marginal benefit curve at the
market level is going to be a decreasing
function of seller effort now this is
true for one market with a given set of
buyers and sellers what happens if the
number of buyers and sellers varies we
can think of these using comparative
statics and so we can think about an
increase in the number of buyers
relative to sellers without affecting
the size of the market and in this case
the services of each seller become
scarcer and scarcer and more valuable
and so we're going to have a shift
outward of the marginal benefit curve
which is going to lead to higher efforts
on the seller site and to higher prices
on on on average on the other side on
the other hand that we can actually
think about an increase in market size
as well and we assume that the increase
in market size might make it easier for
sellers to find more profitable tasks
because there's more buyers I might be
able to find more cleaning tasks that
I'm really good at performing and so we
can think of the marginal cost curve
decreasing shifting downward as the
market grows this is going to lead again
to hire effort on the side of the seller
and lower prices because they are
competing more for
for buyers the theory describes these
interaction in a single static market
but you can think of the task rabbit
platform as actually a set of segregated
markets remember that we have we had
seen at the beginning that each buyer
and seller uses the platform for their
cities and matches occur fast so we can
define each city mountain as a separate
market we have 336 of them and for each
market we observe the variables that we
are interested about we observe the
number of buyers posting tasks the
average task posting rate of every
seller buyer sellers making offers and
their offer intensity as well as the
number of matches and the average
transacted price and some assumptions in
the model allow us to impute the number
of buyers and sellers that are active on
the platform but might not have had a
need for a task in a given month or time
for an offer in a given in a given month
and so we're going to estimate these
sure yep the fact that this market is
expanding over time so we are not going
to count for that fact you will see in a
moment that the market is is is growing
in in all the cities and we're actually
going to take these growth as a way to
measure the level of economies of scale
in in the market why we think that these
is an acceptable assumption namely that
the number of buyers and sellers growing
on the market are not affecting all the
officiants expectations on how the
market is going to play out because most
of the growth is driven by awareness of
this platform in this moment so people
come to know the platform by word of
mouth and there's not a lot of marketing
efforts that are tied to specific market
conditions say you know it's the
Christmas season and you invite people
to outsource their shopping on the
platform and so we are just going to use
the growing size of the platform as a
way to estimate the level of economies
of scale and so we're going to have the
aggregate matching and pricing functions
and we're going to have some parameters
that are related to the utility of
buyers and some parameters that are
related to the utility of sellers I'm
not really going to go into the details
of this but these are basically going to
give us the elasticity of demand to
price and the probability of being match
as well as the elasticity of supply to
price and the probability of being
matched and this is the variation we're
going to use these are the most of the
336 markets that we're going to use for
for the project and you can see from
this plot that the ratio of the number
of active buyers to the number of active
sellers has been varying a lot both over
time and across the different cities for
San Francisco for example the red line
here you can see that there are periods
in which there's about a couple of
buyers posting tasks for every seller
submitting offers and there are some
months in which this ratio is about 63
times as large at the same time in any
given month there's some markets in
which there's one or two buyers for
sellers but months in which there's many
more
and this is the market size so as a
Steve was mentioning if we look at the
number of active buyers in log for the
10 major cities on taskrabbit you can
see that it's growing and it's growing
quite linearly so this is in log scale
so it's not an exponential growth in any
given city and the exponential growth is
just given from the fact that these
platform is basically entering new
series in overtime and this is the key
identifying assumptions although i
should mention that even relaxing it by
considering for example just the number
of new buyers and the number of new
sellers as being independent of an
absurd characteristics on the platform
doesn't really change the results and
the results are also robust to other
market definitions we're using market as
a city month set of activities but we
can use bi-weekly markets we can use
markets that are just for the top tasks
and the results still hold but this is
what we need the number of buyers and
sellers is independent on unobserved
characteristics that affect the
efficiency of the market in any given
city month and it's supported by some
evidence that there's very limited
median advertising because taskrabbit
didn't have a lot of money to spend on
advertising during this period and there
is very limited forward-looking behavior
by buyers and sellers at the same time
there is also some variation in the
cellar screening that we are exploiting
you saw the huge ham shaped of the buyer
to seller ratio and the huge decrease
was due to a change in the policies of
taskrabbit that moved from a really
tight screening policy of sellers to a
not much more luxe policy and so the
first result is on the aggregate
functions of prices and a matching which
support some of the early graphic of
results that we've we've seen at the
beginning so the price doesn't really
change much with the number of tasks or
offers it's about constant doubling the
number of tasks only increases the in
significantly by 1.5% and doubling the
number of offers decreases it by one
point three percent so it's a very
minimal effect of the number of tasks
and offers on prices what is interesting
is the elasticity of the number of
matches to tasks and offers doubling the
number of tasks increases the number of
matches by forty-one percent and
doubling the number of offers increases
it by fifty two percent so they both
contribute about equally to the creation
of matches and the sum of these two
coefficients because of the cobb-douglas
assumption is basically an estimate of
the degree of economies of scale of
efficiency that comes from a larger
market some of these two coefficients
greater than one would be evidence of
economies of scale and of course we
don't see here and this might be due to
the fact that the markets still are
growing but they're fairly small
relative to to the population in in any
given city so the economies of scale are
not evident for these size of the market
but we're not ruling them out for larger
sizes importantly we're allowing for
different matching efficiencies across
cities so we allow for the fact that the
same number of offers and tasks can be
matched at higher rates in different
cities and that's exactly what happens
if we estimate these productivity
parameters you can actually see that
cities like San Francisco and Boston are
twice as effective
converting the same number of offers and
tasks in two matches as cities like
Philadelphia Phoenix Denver on and and
Miami and we have some correlations of
to understand these differences across
cities you can think that because this
level and nature of services is such
that we need buyers and sellers to meet
to transact you can think of more
successful cities as the cities where
the distance between buyers and sellers
is actually smaller and indeed if we
plot the median distance between tasks
and offers in a given city for the month
of May 2014 the last in our data you can
see that San Francisco Boston in your
city have much have buyers and sellers
that live much closer together than
other cities like Houston Atlanta or or
Phoenix and another another way in which
this market is that is yeah sellers you
mean
the mashed fire sincerness or randomly
it's three different measures so you can
actually think of the median distance
between tasks and the offers that
arrived in the 48 hours following the
posting of a task you can think of the
median distance between tasks and offers
that they have received and you can
think of the median distance between the
matched tasks and offers and they are
all going in this direction which is
that related to scroll just city sprawl
you know like Phoenix is really sprawled
out yeah so yeah yeah so we actually
related it to the density of at the at
the city level and then that has some
explanatory power but not completely so
Philadelphia and San Diego are kind of
two big exemptions on this graph so
what's good this was ever stand by
Philadelphia San Francisco p go over
there so what causes the distance to be
big in those cities so I'm interestingly
i was i was talking about someone from
from san diego and the level of
segregation might play a role so buyers
and sellers actually live in very
different name might be living in very
different neighborhoods and so even if
you increase the number of buyers and
sellers you're now going to have them
live closer together
and another way in which the the match
efficiency can can be explained is
through the level of task
standardization and again this is an
another measure that is platform
specific but I mentioned that there is a
standardized tasks and more
heterogeneous tasks but the share of the
standardized tasks like moving health or
grocery and and delivery is different
across the cities San Francisco has a
higher share of these more standardized
tasks for which the supply might be
easier to find and the sellers might be
more substitutable among each other then
the city is where the metric is is is
lower and finally some results on the
utility parameters what I'm going to say
about this is basically that all the
estimation implied that we have a very
elastic offer supply increasing the
price by ten percent increases the
number of offers supplied by about
thirty percent and the gains from each
trade that the platform creates are on
the order of thirty seven dollars which
is the difference between the average
value for the task for the buyer and the
average opportunity cost for the task
for the seller and so because the price
has doesn't have a lot of room to move
and to adjust between these two values
the only two ways in which the market
can equilibrate is either through a very
elastic labor supply which is the case
that we find or through by rationing so
by you're just having a harder time
finding matches when they are abundant
relative to supply and so we can
actually compute the benefits of an
elastic labor supply compared to the
alternative market clearing mechanism
which sees buyers having a harder time
finding
matches when they are in abundance and
so if we look at the aggregate value of
matches on TaskRabbit and we compare
that aggregate value to a world in which
the sellers are submitting a fixed
number of offers because they have a
fixed amount of time in any given month
to provide services on TaskRabbit we can
see that fifteen percent how your value
is generated in on TaskRabbit then if
the seller had an inelastic labor supply
and this is equally shared these
increasing value is equally shared by
buyers and sellers there's fifteen
percent higher revenue for the platform
and for the buyers and this comes at the
cost of sellers because it's more costly
for them to search through task and
submit offers at the same time our
estimates are going to allow us to make
make a back-of-the-envelope estimate of
the value generated by these online
platforms which is on the order of about
10 billion per year in the eighteen US
cities where taskrabbit is currently
active now is this completely value
created or is this cannibalization of
existing of existing industries i I
can't tell I can't attribute the share
to each of these two possibilities but
because many of these tasks are tasks
like moving help or furniture assembly
where previous standard existing markets
didn't really exist you might think that
these is mostly value creation and so to
conclude we presented a framework to
study these possible mechanisms for
market equilibration and we've applied
it in the context of taskrabbit we've
seen that the sellers effort equilibrate
market and buyers are not rationed when
they are abundant and there there are
very limited economies of scale as the
market grows that don't come from a
matching function that displays
increasing returns to scale but from a
reduction in search costs to the sellers
and the city's b'fer in the level of
success finally this is a general
framework for peer-to-peer markets where
the services are typically standardized
and generic and the local and rapid
nature of matching makes the market
inherently thin and very temporarily and
geographically defined and so the
advantage of highly flexible labor
supply is appealing for other other
platforms but not necessarily achievable
by all other platforms and so part of
the reason why over uses surge pricing
is exactly to try to balance buyers
response to use substitute services and
the sellers willingness to provide more
rides as well as Airbnb large inventory
of rooms is a way to expand capacity to
accommodate peak season and limit
rationing
yeah a little bit about why you think
price doesn't respond in these
particular cases you a maybe you've
lastly glanced over really quickly on
that side so the the price is actually
at about sixty dollars so it's not it's
pretty close to the seventy dollars
estimate of the buyers value so there
was really not much room to go up at
least when you expect it to go up all
the way to 70 limitations in principle
it could in principle it could it just
doesn't doesn't happen because the
elasticity of supply just allows buyers
to get the task done for something lower
I'm not sure where you're but do you
think is a lot of suppliers just have
capacity so they do and that would
explain why they expand their capacity
in periods of high demand but at the
same time it doesn't completely explain
why they shrink their offers the number
of hours in periods of low demand so the
question is what's their opportunity
cost of time right and or leisure yeah
right if they have a pretty fixed
opportunity cost of leisure and they
really are substituting between leisure
but because they have this
supply price is going to be pretty
insensitive kind of at the cost of
leisure unless demand skyrockets which
property it doesn't it doesn't yeah yeah
so that's that's that that helps explain
the fact that price doesn't change
another possibility is that these tasks
for some of these tasks the price is
very clearly determined cleaning is
about 30 hours thirty dollars per hour
and so it you can easily subsidy the way
and then it's very different welfare
implications relative to the idea that
these guys are sort of labor and elastic
right relate elastic I should say right
so if you think about if you think about
the leisure time argument that speed was
making that's a totally different
interpretation relative to the idea that
what happens if you raise price a little
bit if you leave the market you go
somewhere else yeah but that doesn't
that doesn't prevent supply from still
being very elastic
so I mean to which extent is there like
a substitution winch ask sorry and so
people who do meaning can they start
doing something else once there's how
you mean there's yeah so we actually
initially started looking at the
different has categories separately but
then we realized that there's a lot of
there's a lot of sellers actually
providing services in many categories so
of the sellers for example submitting 10
or more offers more than sixty percent
of them submit offers in more than two
or three categories and so that makes
dividing the marketing two different
categories separately a little bit
trickier second question so in regarding
the tasks to which extent are the task
requesters individuals versus like I you
know I'm a cleaning company I'm missing
a cleaning crew I just want somebody
very quick so my Quattro actually has
another paper on businesses asking for
multiple sellers to provide services
like user experience for for for
software development for example most
the great majority about ninety percent
are private individuals or at least they
self-identify as private individuals
fix again